es gibt menschen die wollen sie am
allerliebsten abschaffen dabei sind suvs
die mit abstand beliebtesten autos in
deutschland kein fahrzeugsegment
verkauft sich so gut wie dieser ist das
war gerade oder ist gerade auch auf der
internationalen automobil ausstellung zu
sehen heute wurde die von angela merkel
eröffnet und neben vielen neuen
elektroautos präsentieren die hersteller
da eben auch die modelle mit denen sie
am meisten geld verdienen und das sind
hoch motorisierte suv
was steckt denn hinter dem hype um suvs
was ist aber auch dran an der kritik
darüber möchte ich heute mit matthias
malmedie sprechen
er testet hauptberuflich autos vor
laufender kamera unter anderem auf
seinem youtube kanal und wenn ihr fragen
an ihn habt dann könnt ihr sie gerne
hier unten in die kommentarspalte posten
wir stellen euch hat aber erstmal
matthias malmedie vor
ich weiß nicht wie alt ich da war egal
was ich im fernsehen gesehen habe egal
welche filme welche serien mit den
verschiedensten fahrzeugen ab ich szenen
nachgespielt und da fing das glaube ich
an dass ich tatsächlich so auto
gesteuert geworden bin ich dass heute
immer noch
und ich habe den schlüssel
ich habe nicht nur den schlüssel das
auto ich habe straße ich habe sprit es
ist zeit auszuflippen
[Musik]
und matthias malmedie sitzt jetzt nicht
für uns in einem auto sondern für uns im
studio in köln ist mir live zugeschaltet
guten abend herr malmedy schön genau
haben die sie testen unterschiedlichste
auto sitzen in unterschiedlichsten
modellen würde es für sie in frage
kommen privat auch ein suv zu fahren das
kann ich ganz klar mit ja beantworten
ich muss ganz ehrlich gestehen auch wenn
ich natürlich über ja die probleme weiß
die so ein großes auto mit sich bringt
wenn man da vor allen dingen alleine
drin sitzt ich stehe trotzdem auch diese
autos ich glaube das sind die gleichen
gründe warum ich diese autos mag warum
alle anderen leute diese autos im moment
so gerne kaufen
es ist das hohe sitzen es ist irgendwie
ja dieses freiheitsgefühl dass du das
gefühl hast du kannst damit bis ans
andere ende der welt kommen quasi egal
was kommt egal welchen berg zu erklimmen
musst du kommst mit diesem auto dach
hoch und das ist so ein stück weit
freiheit einfach die du in so einem auto
spürst aber ich glaube tatsächlich dass
es für die meisten käufer momentan so
ist dass das hohe sitzen eines der
hauptmerkmale ist warum sie so ein auto
so ein suv kaufen aber es hat trotzdem
sagen so ein auto bringt auch viele
nachteile parkplatzsuche mann passt zum
beispiel in kein parkhaus so richtig
rein mit diesen autos trotzdem kaufen
eben ein drittel der leute oder ein
drittel der zugelassenen autos auf
deutschen straßen sind diese erste wies
was hinter genau die beweggründe lassen
sie uns noch mal weiter erörtern
ja ich hab's ja gerade gesagt also dass
das hauptthema glaube ich ist dass die
leute gerne weit oben sitzen und in dem
auto halten eine gewisse übersicht haben
also vor allen dingen auch ältere leute
mögen das sehr sehr gerne so weit oben
zu sitzen und das ist der grund warum
diese autos so viel verkauft werden
übrigens in dem teaser habe ich gelesen
ja spritfresser und so weiter und so
fort
das stimmt natürlich aber es gibt diese
angeblich hochwertigen suvs auch in
kleineren varianten die sehr sehr
sparsam sind mit dreizylinder motoren
die großen motoren haben
zylinderabschaltung und die verbrauchen
jetzt so viel wie ganz normale
limousinen vor zehn jahren also das ist
ich sehe das problem auch dass diese
autos
so richtig super sind für unsere umwelt
aber sie sind viel sehr viel effizienter
geworden als sie das vor ein paar jahren
waren und insofern ja kann man es
verstehen dass die leute das quasi in
kauf nehmen und sich sagen hey ich will
gerne hochsitzen auch für ältere leute
dass ein steigendes einfacher und es ist
natürlich auch ein statussymbol für
viele viele leute die sich sagen ich
habe dir den dicksten offenen hof los
bitte los lassen sie uns mal in die
kommentare ein bisschen gucken
die kommen natürlich auch kritik an svs
zum beispiel marina schreibt das sind
egoisten panzer mit dem hashtag suv
verbot
es sind das so sachen die ihnen in ihrem
job auch mal begegnen das sie der kritik
bekommen
ehrlich gesagt nicht bei uns in unseren
kanälen in unserem umkreis so sind die
leute natürlich schon auch
selbstkritisch und sagen sich ja gut das
muss nicht unbedingt sein das jetzt
irgendwie die mami mit ihrem
zweijährigen kind morgens mit dem
porsche cayenne in die kita fährt ja das
finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt quatsch
aber ich kann verstehen dass die leute
es kaufen und die autoindustrie baut
diese autos weil sie gekauft werden und
das geht von top nach unten also es fing
damit an die ganz großen suvs zu bauen
und jetzt bauen die autohersteller ganz
kleine suv weil auch die jungen leute
die jetzt quasi ein auto sich kaufen
möchten diese autos cool finden und das
cool finden hoch zu setzen und dieses
gefühl von freiheit eben auszuleben
denn was sie vorher noch gesagt haben
zum thema parkplatzsuche und die
parkhäuser sind zu eng
diese kleinen suvs die sind nicht größer
als ein golf oder als ein ganz normales
auto
auch die mittelgroßen sind nicht größer
als ein 3er bmw oder mercedes c klasse
also das ist die sind zwar sehr sehr
breit aber alle autos werden sehr sehr
viel breiter und haben dieses
parkplatzproblem das ist kein problem
von suvs das ist ein problem generell
von allen autos die werden alle breiter
weil alle mehr platz wollen mehr
sicherheit auch wollen das auch ein
grund warum die autos immer breiter
werden damit der seitenaufprall
gewährleistet ist und das bringt das
alles mit sich wenn wir alle mit den
autos aus den siebzigern rumfahren
würden dann hätten wir keine
parkplatzprobleme absolut da wird auch
viel bisschen zusammen gewürfelt dann
über suv gesprochen wird es gibt die
schweren großen suvs und es gibt
natürlich auch die mini suvs und in der
debatte wird da manchmal nicht richtig
differenziert was ich spannend finde
hier in den kommentaren hier kommt
einiges das geht so ein bisschen in die
richtung
warum wird eigentlich aber es gemerkt
hat und nicht über andere sachen ihr
schreibt zb victoria bei facebook man
schimpft eigentlich mal einer über den
familien bus oder andre schreibt der
uralt vw bulli der dann neben mir steht
das ist schlimmer als die suvs oder die
mini suvs oder hier eine ganz generell
sache christ christian schreibt wozu
braucht überhaupt pkws mit mehr als 100
ps und die frage will ich eigentlich
ganz gerne an sie weitergeben
warum stürzen sich jetzt alle mit ihrer
kritik auf die suvs weil man könnte
jetzt auch sagen zb sportwagen sind
umweltfreundlich ja sportwagen sind also
sind nicht für die umwelt gebaut aber
bei sportwagen ist das thema glaube ich
relativ schnell erledigt weil sportwagen
werden nicht bewegt wie ganz normale
autos sportwagen werden am wochenende
raus geholt wenn man irgendwie eine
schöne fahrt machen will verlängertes
wochenende keine ahnung wohin du machst
ein ausflug auf die rennstrecke dafür
brauchst du ein sportwagen und dort
werden sportwagen eingesetzt aber die
jahreslaufleistung als die
kilometerleistung von dem sportwagen ist
viel viel geringer als die von einem
jeglichen weil sie nicht vw passats die
irgendwie als vertreter autos auf den
deutschen autobahnen unterwegs sind und
insofern ist sportwagen fahren glaube
ich echt okay weil das einen so kleinen
anteil an den ausschüssen und am
feinstaub und so weiter ausmacht dass
man das wirklich vernachlässigen kann
und muss natürlich auch sagen das ist
ein stück weit auch in der kultur
ja das ist ja sportwagen sind ja nicht
einfach nur fortbewegungsmittel ganz im
gegenteil das ist etwas wo man frühen
kann wo man bock drauf hat wo man lust
und spaß dran hat und ich erlebt dass so
egal mit welchem sportwagen ich gerade
unterwegs bin das ist was was die leute
faszinierend finden worüber sie sich
freuen wenn du durch die stadt fährt die
leute gucken klar gibt es auch mal einen
irgendwie daumen nach unten macht weil
ja zu hause losgefahren müssen ist auch
quatsch in der stadt
aber die leute interessieren sich dafür
die kleinen jungs aber auch die großen
mädchen alle gucken sie den autos
hinterher und mögen diese autos lesen
die auto zeitschriften und gucken unsere
filme egal ob youtube oder auf rtl 2
das ist einfach das was die leute
interessiert was sie mögen und das ist
auch ein stück weit keine ahnung wie
golfen und wenn man mir vorwirft ich
fahre zu viel sportwagen oder
keine ahnung was ich so alles gemacht
habe in meinem autofahrerleben ich kenne
leute die fliegen an weihnachten nach
new york zum shoppen und das nicht
glaube ich ein bisschen krasser als im
jahr 3000 kilometer mit einem
lamborghini irgendwas zu fahren ich
werde auf jeden fall schon raus ihr herz
schlägt ein bisschen höher für
sportwagen als für essen wie ich das
schön ist dass das auch in kombination
geht ja ja wir reden ja gleich noch
weiter also wir sprechen nämlich gleich
tatsächlich noch weiter wir haben die
kritik jetzt schon ein bisschen
angerissen und die geht ja bei manchen
soweit zum beispiel bei manchen grünen
politikern dass sie sogar eine
obergrenze für suvs in innenstädten
fordern und auch die umwelthilfe hat
sich dazu geäußert und da haben wir
jetzt mal rein
wir müssen erreichen dass die
insbesondere diese besonders großen und
schweren statt panzer dass die
weitestgehend in unseren städten
verschwinden und eben wenn überhaupt
dann kleine oder mittelgroße fahrzeuge
dort unterwegs sind aber auf keinen fall
diese großen stadt geländewagen die eben
besonders schädlich auch fürs klima sind
wir haben nie ein grundsätzliches verbot
von suv gefordert wir haben gesagt dass
in deutschen städten die schweren suv es
eben soweit benachteiligt werden sollten
beispielsweise durch eine city maut oder
noch besser über park beschränkungen
dass eben diese fahrzeuge dann weniger
werden in unseren städten und da will
ich natürlich direkt mal ein haken
was halten sie denn von seiner idee
einer maut oder zum beispiel einer
obergrenze
also obergrenze hätte ich gerne ein
bisschen näher dies definiert war es das
größte höhe ps-zahl was ist die
obergrenze oder das war die obergrenze
betrug sich tatsächlich auf die anzahl
von großen schweren suv es in
innenstädten wie das dann genau
umgesetzt werden muss dann müsste man
dann wahrscheinlich noch mal gucken wie
man vieles müsste also ich habe so das
gefühl dass ihnen diesen ganzen debatten
egal ob es um es jetzt geht oder um
elektroautos dass da jeder soja kommen
das machen wir jetzt so und so und dann
wird das schon
ich glaube da müssen wir erst mal ein
bisschen nachdenken und wirklich
überlegen was es da der richtige weg zum
thema suvs muss ich sagen eine city-maut
ja ok meinetwegen aber dann für alle
meinetwegen nach kiel nach tonnen
irgendwie gestaffelt völlig okay ich
finde auch dass den städten zu viele
autos unterwegs sind
du kannst du fast nicht mehr fahren also
wenn du münchen zb als beispiel nimmst
da kann man fast nicht mehr fahren das
ist nur noch ein start verkehr und das
ja kann man gerne machen erhöhte weil
sie nicht parkgebühren finde ich alles
okay aber ein grundsätzliches verbot ist
in meinen augen totaler quatsch
wie kommt ein kommentar von mz bei
youtube der schreibt oder die schreibt
umweltschädliche dinge extrem hoch
besteuern wäre das auch eine idee
einfach ganz generell steuern erhöhen
ja klar heißt ich meine das muss
irgendwie verhältnismäßig sein wie alles
verhältnismäßig sein muss aber klar kann
man auch sagen okay leute wenn ihr
unbedingt alleine mit einem audi q7
durch die stadt fahren wollt dann müsste
halt dafür bezahlen genauso wie ihr das
auto ja erstmal auch bezahlen ist
allerdings muss natürlich auch sagen
dass die steuern für so ein auto für so
ein großes auto eh schon höher sind als
für kleines auto also das wäre dann halt
der doppelbelastung deswegen sage ich
das muss alles verhältnismäßig sein und
da muss man sich wirklich viele gedanken
darüber machen
und ja jetzt kommt anfang dieser woche
das thema auf und dann springen alle
rein
die dinge müssen wir verbieten also das
ist wirklich quatsch weil dann fährt
irgendwie auch kein handwerker mehr in
die stadt und guckt nach dem verstopfen
rohr weil viele handwerker fahren solche
dinge auch damit sie auch nach hinten
dranhängen können
also es ist man sollte da schon ein
bisschen mehr darüber nachdenken finde
ich wir haben jetzt schon ein bisschen
über die enge in den innenstädten
gesprochen aber es gibt natürlich auch
noch den klima aspekt und da wenn wir
uns auch noch mal was zu anschauen
ein lukrativer boom für die autobauer
für die klima- und umweltbilanz ein
problem die ps-starken großen schlucken
insgesamt deutlich mehr kraftstoff als
kleinwagen stoßen damit auch mehr co2
aus und giftige stickoxide vor allem
wenn sie diesel tanken das sind noch gut
20 prozent aller neuen suvs
aber was macht sie zu solchen
spritschluckern ein großer anteil geht
auf das konto des gewichts und der
aerodynamik
hier gilt je geringer der luftwiderstand
eines autos desto größer die ersparnis
suvs aber haben beispielsweise eine xxl
stirnfläche somit einen hohen
luftwiderstand und einen höheren
spritverbrauch ideal für wüsten schnee
oder schotterstraßen für deutsche
innenstädte wohl kaum gut jeder zweite
hat einen allradantrieb
damit kommt weiteres gewicht dazu und
noch mehr spritverbrauch auch die räder
eines autos beeinflussen den
spritverbrauch ihr größer und breiter
der reifen desto mehr steigt der
spritverbrauch
außerdem haben breitere reifen mehr
kontaktfläche mit der straße das
bedeutet mehr reifenabrieb mehr
feinstaub und kleinste mikropartikel die
in die luft gelangen das macht es zu
einem echten umweltprobleme und über
dieses umweltproblemen wollen wir
natürlich auch weiter sprechen
das sind ja jetzt fakten die wir gerade
im stück gehört haben die werden
wahrscheinlich auch den meisten suv
fahrern irgendwie geläufig sein
und sie sprechen ja mit wahrscheinlich
mit vielen ist denn der umweltschutz
nicht so wichtig also ehrlich gesagt ich
nicht so viel mit suv fahrern soll er
mit sportwagen fahren aber ich meine
klar ist den leuten das nicht wichtig
klar ist dass eine egoistische
entscheidung sich so ein auto zu kaufen
das auch täglich im stadtverkehr zu
benutzen
ich hab's ja eingangs schon gesagt dass
ich das auch nicht für besonders
sinnvoll halte allerdings muss man
natürlich auch sehen ob der markt
verlangt danach die menschen wollen
diese autos haben also kann man
zumindest mal die autohersteller nicht
an den pranger stellen sein wieso baut
die diese dinger ja weil sie gekauft
werden wollen also ich würde auch nicht
anders machen wenn mir sagt jemand hier
ist ganz immer irgendwie kein neues
handy erfinden ich kaufe dir das ab dann
empfinde ich das neue handy sage ich mal
so ja also das ist kann ich schon sehr
gut verstehen
natürlich sind diese autos haben erhöhte
kraftstoff ausstöße und so weiter und so
fort wo man da auch sagen muss dass das
wirklich die autohersteller sehr sehr
ernst nehmen auch diese autos mit segel
funktionen mit sich
der abschaltung auszustatten und
natürlich gibt es auch jetzt
mittlerweile viele elektroautos die als
sed gebaut werden bzw sowie die als
elektroauto gebaut werden und das ist
ein trend der im moment noch da ist weil
natürlich die in dem großen suv viele
batterien unterbringen kannst und unsere
bevölkerung ist so gestrickt dass sie
gerne weit fahren möchten also mit einer
reichweite von 200 kilometern möchte
keine auskommen deswegen kannst du so
was nicht im golf reinbauen deswegen
brauchst du mehr platz also nimmst du es
brauchst doch viele viele batterien rein
dann kannst du vier kilometer fahren und
dann sagt der mensch wieder okay 40
kilometer dass das reicht mir und dann
nehme ich das so insm suv haben wir den
salat
bei elektro auto würde ich jetzt auch
ganz gerne direkt einen haken heute auf
der iaa da hat merkel auch von einem
umbruch gesprochen hat ihm gesagt es
geht der trend jetzt so immer mehr
elektroautos sehen sie das dass das bald
wirklich kommt das kommt definitiv also
ich meine alle autohersteller arbeiten
oder haben schon elektroautos auf den
markt volkswagen mit dem vw id3 heißt da
das ist jetzt quasi der golf unter den
elektroautos der mir kann man jetzt
schon bestellen die erste charge ist
quasi schon ausverkauft und die autos
kommen aber erst mitte 2020 auf dem
markt also auch da sieht man so ein
riesengroßer konzern ist nicht sofort
bereit und kriegt es sofort hin und
elektro auto für jedermann quasi auf die
beine zu stellen oder auf die räder
vielmehr das auto soll mit der
geringsten reichweite unter 30.000 euro
kosten was immer noch viel mehr ist als
ein vergleichbares auto als verbrenner
oder diesel
aber damit müssen wir alle leben frau
merkel hat gesagt jetzt fahren wir
bitten alle elektro- und ich glaube 2030
sollen sieben millionen elektroautos
sagt sein und auf den straßen unterwegs
sondern genau 2020 sollten ist auch
schon eine million sein also so richtig
halten wir es ja bisher nicht deswegen
auch noch mal da die nachfrage und die
kommen dazu tatsächlich nämlich auch
viele kommentare silas bei youtube
schreibt zum beispiel denkt ihr dass
elektroautos die zukunft sind oder eher
hybrid oder sonstiges und dazu passt
auch die frage von büren der schreibt er
hat das suv oder wasserstoff suv sind
dass alternativen
das halte ich also vor einiges
wasserstoff suv halte ich für einen sehr
sehr geniale sting vor jahren schon hat
bmw lange am wasserstoff rum entwickelt
jetzt hat gerade mercedes mit dem f cell
ein wasserstoffauto auf markt gefallen
was ich auch schon gefahren bin und das
ist ein absolut geniales autos fährt
sich wie ein elektroauto aber es tankt
wie ein ganz normales benzin auto und
das ist das schöne daran den wasserstoff
kann man relativ normal an der zapfsäule
tanken
der tankvorgang dauer circa 56 minuten
je nachdem wie großer tank ist und dann
fährst du mit diesen
brennstoffzellenauto zirka 4 500
kilometer weit und dann fährst dann die
nächste wasserstofftankstelle sofern
vorhanden
daran müssen auch arbeiten genauso wie
bei an den elektro zapfsäulen quasi
arbeiten müssen aber da fährst du da an
die zapfsäule tanks wieder fünf minuten
du kannst wieder 540 meter weiter fahren
findet er das ist ein
sehen sie denn das was auch bei den
herstellern so angekommen ist dass das
auch noch einen ein weiterer fahrt wäre
der eingeschlagen wird
im moment sieht man ja vor allem autos
ja das ist ja natürlich vor allen dingen
von der bundesregierung so gefordert
das jetzt bitte alles auf elektro gehen
soll und deswegen machen die
autohersteller das auch und das ist
natürlich ein problem finde ich
zumindest wenn man sollte diese anderen
technologien also die brennstoffzelle
ist die eine andere technologie gibt
noch biomethan was der kollege niklas
glaube ich in seinem kommentar
geschrieben hat das ist eine andere
möglichkeit das ist komplett co2 neutral
also da wird einfach struck war sie
umgewandelt in biomethan und damit kann
man dann ganz normal auto fahren
sensationell in der augsburg fahrrad
fährt damit die gesamte flotte von den
öffentlichen verkehrs bussen durch die
gegend in berlin allerdings wo die
regierung ist davon sie alle mit
elektrobussen durch die gegend die
erstmal gebaut werden mussten und so
weiter und so fort und wenn es im winter
kalt ist dann brauchen die irgendwie
eine reizung was machen dann die
elektrobusse die schalten eine diese
heizung eine zusatzheizung also das ist
eine super idee gewesen auf jeden fall
und in augsburg da machen sie es richtig
gut
kompliment dahin mal ganz kurz von
meiner seite
also ich höre da gibt es noch einige
unterschiedliche optionen wie man
einfach die außenseiter gemacht werden
momentan und die anders gemacht werden
müssen also mehr in brennstoffzellen zum
beispiel die technologien
weiterentwickelt genau und die
alternativen kraftstoffe die es geben
wird wo man dann wieder ganz normaler
verbrennungsmotoren mit speisen kann
die müssen auch weiter gefördert werden
dass die entwicklung einfach voran geht
da sollte man auch geld reinstecken auf
jeden fall
vielen dank für das gespräch danke dass
sie sich heute für uns zeit genommen
haben und das werden wir natürlich
weiter verfolgen und ich bedanke mich
auch bei euch fürs zu sehen für die
vielen fragen wir konnten gar nicht alle
abarbeiten die reingekommen sind aber
ich hoffe einige konnten wir dann doch
beantworten
die nächsten streamen den gibt's hier am
dienstag dann ist daniel wieder für euch
da und wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn
ihr dann wieder einschaltet und wenn
euch dieser live-stream gefallen hat
dann interessiert ihr euch vielleicht
auch für diesen hier
da ging es darum was die reform der
straßenverkehrsordnung bringt oder
vielleicht auch der hier
da ging es darum ob der br jemals fertig
gebaut wird oder er klickt mal hier
da könnt ihr den neuen zdf- heute-
youtube-kanal abonnieren
[Musik]